Is "MONSTER" an accurate look at Jeffrey
Dahmer's life and crimes, or does it
sensationalize beyond recognition? Here's the
verdict on Netflix's latest true-crime hit.
The "true" in "true crime" is
sometimes a bit misleading. Yes,
the stories are based on real events,
but the people behind the stories often
use some dramatic license to make it more
engaging for the viewer, listener, or reader.
This was very likely on the mind of Ryan
Murphy, the writer, director, producer,
and creator of countless hit TV shows, as he
was developing Netflix's most recent foray
into dramatized true crime, "MONSTER: The
Jeffrey Dahmer Story." Online buzz around
the show is already electric, but viewers may be
wondering how much of the story actually happened.
Murphy allegedly has a spotty track record
regarding accuracy in his projects, many of
which skew toward retelling real events. Whether
chronicling the court cases of O.J. Simpson,
the impeachment of former president Bill Clinton,
the "feud" between Bette Davis and Joan Crawford,
or the murder of Gianni Versace, the
filmmaker is clearly attracted to real-life
events that involved lots of drama. While he
definitely sometimes embellishes reality for
artistic effect, some have accused him of
stretching the truth beyond recognition.
According to Rose Law Group, actor Olivia de
Havilland filed a lawsuit against FX and Murphy,
alleging that her portrayal in "Feud"
tarnished her reputation and put words
in her mouth. And the Halston family called
the Ewan McGregor-led drama "Halston," which
chronicled the titular real-life fashion
designer, "inaccurate" and "fictionalized"
in a statement. If Murphy's detractors are
to be believed, it may be challenging to
take his most recent project at face value.
Yet Decider has fact-checked "MONSTER," and
their findings draw a unique conclusion
for the true crime genre, proclaiming
that it "May Be One of the Most Accurate True
Crime Dramatizations Brought to Television."
Decider asserts that most of the
series' outrageous and disturbing
events actually did occur. This seems
to be especially true for the specter
of institutional malpractice haunting this
case. Glenda Cleveland's ignored police call
and the failure to save 14-year-old Konerak
Sinthasomphone are both noted as accurate,
right down to a gross joke made
by one of the police officers.
"It'll be a minute. My partner's got
to go get deloused at the station."
Decider argues that the show is actually
more compelling by sticking to actual events,
even to the point of showcasing an empathetic
side of Dahmer, depicting him as someone who
was ultimately failed by the system. Still,
they report that "MONSTER" resists the trope
of glorifying Dahmer, presenting him in
as realistic and unattractive a light as
possible. While the show explores the societal
causes and implications of Dahmer's actions,
the victims whose lives were destroyed by
those very actions are always of paramount
importance. Actor Evan Peters, who
plays Dahmer in the series, said,
"It felt important to be respectful to
the victims, to the victims' families."
Decider does note some small inaccuracies.
The real Dahmer did not drink blood from a
bag while working at a plasma center;
he consumed it from a vial. Similarly,
Dahmer's own killer, Christopher Scarver,
is shown to attack fellow inmate Jesse
Anderson before going to Dahmer. In reality,
Scarver stated that he attacked Dahmer first.
Historical accuracy feels
especially important when
dealing with such a well-known subject
as Jeffrey Dahmer. It's all too easy to
forget his victims and conjure a distracting
image of a cinematic criminal mastermind. But
mythologizing Dahmer would be failing to
learn the lessons of this horrific story.
The most recent film about the killer, "My Friend
Dahmer," followed the killer's last years in high
school and took a deliberately accurate approach
as well. The graphic novel the film is based on
was autobiographical. Its writer, John Backderf,
began writing the story of their friendship after
news about Dahmer's crimes became public.
The idiosyncrasies he and others had seen
and bushed off were suddenly missed signals. In
a 2012 interview with Publishers Weekly, he said,
"It just seems to me that at every crucial
point on his march to the edge of the abyss,
it was an adult's failure that
propelled him along the way."
These themes of institutional
failure and the consequences of
societal neglect are likewise
found in Murphy's "MONSTER."